[Music]
it's not hard to imagine a world where
at any given moment you and everyone you
know could be wiped out without warning
at the push of a button this was the
reality for millions of people during
the 45 year period after World War two
now known as the cold war as the United
States and Soviet Union faced off across
the globe each knew that the other had
nuclear weapons capable of destroying it
and destruction never loomed closer than
during the 13 days of the Cuban Missile
Crisis in 1961 the u.s. unsuccessfully
tried to overthrow Cuba's new communist
government that failed attempt was known
as the Bay of Pigs and it convinced Cuba
to seek help from the USSR Soviet
premier Nikita Khrushchev was happy to
comply by secretly deploying nuclear
missiles to Cuba not only to protect the
island but to counteract the threat from
US missiles in Italy and Turkey by the
time US intelligence discovered the plan
the materials to create the missiles
were already in place at an emergency
meeting on October 16 1962 military
advisors urged an airstrike on missile
sites and invasion of the island but
President John F Kennedy chose a more
careful approach on October 22nd he
announced that the u.s. Navy would
intercept all shipments to Cuba there
was just one problem a naval blockade
was considered an act of war although
the president called it a quarantine
that did not block basic necessities the
Soviets didn't appreciate the
distinction in an outraged letter to
Kennedy Khrushchev wrote the violation
of freedom to use international waters
and international airspace is an act of
aggression which pushes mankind toward
the abyss of world nuclear missile war
thus ensued the most intense six days of
the Cold War while the u.s. demanded the
removal of the missiles Cuba and the
USSR insisted they were only defensive
and as the
fans continued to be armed the u.s.
prepared for a possible invasion on
October 27th a spy plane piloted by
major Rudolf Anderson was shot down by a
Soviet missile the same day a
nuclear-armed Soviet submarine was hit
by a small depth charge from a US Navy
vessel trying to signal it to come up
the commanders on the sub too deep to
communicate with the surface thought war
had begun and prepared to launch a
nuclear torpedo that decision had to be
made unanimously by three officers the
captain and political officer both
authorized the launch but Vasili
arkhipov second-in-command refused his
decision saved the day and perhaps the
world but the crisis wasn't over for the
first time in history the US military
set itself to DEFCON 2
the defense readiness one step away from
nuclear war with hundreds of nuclear
missiles ready to launch the
metaphorical Doomsday Clock stood at one
minute to midnight but diplomacy carried
on in Washington DC attorney General
Robert Kennedy secretly met with Soviet
ambassador Anatoly Dobrynin after
intense negotiation they reached the
following proposal the US would remove
their missiles from Turkey and Italy and
promised to never invade Cuba in
exchange for the Soviet withdrawal from
Cuba under UN inspection once the
meeting had concluded de Brennan cabled
Moscow saying time is of the essence and
we shouldn't miss the chance and at 9:00
a.m. the next day a message arrived from
Khrushchev announcing the Soviet
missiles would be removed from Cuba the
crisis was now over while criticized at
the time by their respective governments
for bargaining with the enemy
contemporary historical analysis shows
great admiration for Kennedy and
Khrushchev ability to diplomatically
solve the crisis but the disturbing
lesson was that a slight communication
error or split-second decision by a
commander could have thwarted all their
efforts as it nearly did if not for
vasili arkhipov courageous choice the
Cuban Missile Crisis
revealed just how fragile human politics
are compared to the terrifying power
they can unleash
you
[Music]